The prosecutor from a district attorney's office in Boston recently told one of the producers or our radio show that from what he's seen, criminals do not take the fall for each other. He said, nobody willingly goes to prison for a crime to help a buddy. There's too much at stake, he said. The circumstances would have to be extraordinary.
波士顿地方检察官办公室的一位检察官最近告诉我们电台的一位制作人，据他所见，罪犯并不会为彼此背黑锅。他说，没有人会为了帮朋友而自愿替罪入狱。他说，代价太大了，除非情况极其特殊。
So I ran this by this guy named Rich Farrell who's spent a lot of time around the Boston mob while co-writing a book with this mobster named Patrick Nee. And who also wrote a book about his own years committing petty crimes and doing heroin. And Rich Farrell did not agree. He said guys take the fall for each other all the time. He told me about two mobsters, and one of them is a buddy of his. He's convinced both did time for murders they didn't commit.
所以我把这个问题拿去问了里奇·法雷尔（Rich Farrell）。他曾与一位名叫帕特里克·尼（Patrick Nee）的黑帮分子合写过一本书，在波士顿黑帮圈子里待过很长时间。他还写过一本书，讲述了自己当年犯下轻罪和吸食海洛因的经历。但里奇·法雷尔并不同意这种说法。他说，这些人经常为彼此背黑锅。他跟我讲了两个黑帮分子的故事，其中一个是他的朋友。他确信这两人都为他们没犯过的谋杀案坐了牢。
It's believable to him because he's taken the fall. This was back when he was on the streets in the 1980s in Lowell, Massachusetts. He says, one time there was this kid.
对他来说这很可信，因为他也替人背过黑锅。那是在20世纪80年代，他还在马萨诸塞州洛厄尔的街头混的时候。他说，有一次，有一个小孩。
There was a kid that was a real scumbag. Listen to me, we were scumbags too. But there's different level of scumbags on the streets. We were drug addicts. We weren't going to rob from old ladies, from kids, from people that weren't engaged in the type of stuff we were. And this kid was known for this coming out of the projects down there. They would run over and they would grab the old lady's pocketbook right out of their arms. And just rip it off them and run.
那是个真正的人渣小孩。听我说，我们也是人渣。但街头上的人渣也有不同等级。我们是瘾君子。我们不会去抢劫老太太，不会抢小孩，也不会抢那些和我们所作所为无关的人。而那个小孩在当地的贫民区里就是干这种事的。他们会跑过去，直接从老太太怀里抢走钱包，扯下来就跑。
So this kid does this to Rich's aunt. And later, the kid is found beat up, badly beat up. And the police accuse Rich of doing it.
后来这个小孩对里奇的姑姑干了这种事。之后，这孩子被发现被打得鼻青脸肿，伤得很重。警察指控是里奇干的。
So the cops must have thought I had cause to do this, but it was actually one of my best friends that I grew up with. He's dead now, Tommy Sparks. I was taken in for it and it came down to my father's friend who was my attorney. He said, to me, Richie, they made a deal. Basically, I had to agree to it. I said, but Gene, I didn't do it. I frigging wasn't even there. The things weren't even there. And he said, hey, Richie-- I'll never forget this-- he said, Richie, did you ever do anything and get away with it? And I smiled and I said, of course. So it was one of those things.
警察一定是认为我有动机这样做，但其实是我从小玩到大最好的朋友之一干的。他现在已经死了，叫汤米·斯帕克斯（Tommy Sparks）。我因为这事被带走，最后还得靠我父亲的朋友，也就是我的律师出面。他对我说，里奇，他们达成了一项协议。基本上，我必须同意。我说，可是吉恩，我没干。我他妈当时根本不在场。那些东西根本就不在那儿。他说，嘿，里奇——我永远忘不了这句话——他说，里奇，你难道没干过什么坏事却没被抓到吗？我笑了笑说，当然。所以这就是那种情况。
The one thing he never would have done he says, is tell them that his friend Tommy did it. That would have been unthinkable.
他说，他唯一绝不会做的事，就是告诉他们是他朋友汤米干的。那简直是不可想象的。
We had that code, that Irish code, that just said, you're not a rat. You don't tell on people. You just take it. It's principle. And I learned it early on.
我们有那种准则，那种爱尔兰人的准则，简单来说就是：你不能当告密者。你不能出卖别人。你就认了吧。这关乎原则。我很早就学会了这一点。
When I was in the seventh grade, 13. I look back, I was 13 years old. We're at a YMCA dance in downtown Lowell. And around 11 o'clock we're cutting back across the city to the Acre, the Irish section, St. Patrick's School was there where we attended school, all the Irish kids. And door's open and Billy Burns had to go to the bathroom. So he went up to the second floor and we went up and Billy had taken one of the urinal pucks and he had put it into the toilet and flushed it.
那是在我七年级的时候，我13岁。回想起来，我当时才13岁。我们在洛厄尔市中心的基督教青年会（YMCA）跳舞。晚上11点左右，我们穿过城市回到埃克尔（Acre），那是爱尔兰人聚居区，圣帕特里克学校就在那里，那是我们所有爱尔兰孩子读书的地方。门开着，比利·伯恩斯（Billy Burns）要去厕所。于是他上了二楼，我们也跟着上去，比利拿了一个小便池里的除味块，把它扔进马桶里冲掉了。
Those little cakes from the urinal?
就是那种小便池里的小方块？
Yeah, those little cakes. And there was water coming out. And we said, let's get out of here. Well, we went home thinking, OK, we're going to make it. No problem. Didn't think anything. The cops came to my door.
对，就是那种小方块。然后水溢出来了。我们说，快跑吧。我们回到家，心想，好吧，我们能过关的。没问题。什么都没想。结果警察找上门来了。
Wow. That's a real response for urinal cakes down a pipe.
哇。因为小便池除味块堵塞管道而有这种反应，真是大动干戈啊。
Yeah, they came to my door and they said that I was the one who threw the puck down. And so I looked up my father standing there and I knew I was in a lot of trouble. My father had a belt that his father had given him from Ireland, and he used to give us what he called, zebra stripes, because it left these red marks. So he called them zebra stripes. I knew I was in trouble. But I also knew by my father's eye something I was taught early on, there's like this Irish code, unwritten, that you just do not tell on anybody. If you get caught at something, if you're involved in something, you just suck it up. That's part of being a man.
是啊，他们来到我家门口，说是我把那个方块扔进去的。我抬头看到我父亲站在那里，我知道我有大麻烦了。我父亲有一条他父亲从爱尔兰带给他的皮带，他过去常给我们留下他所谓的“斑马条纹”，因为会在身上留下红色的痕迹。所以我管它们叫斑马条纹。我知道我要倒霉了。但我从父亲的眼神中也读出了我早年学到的东西，那是一种爱尔兰人的潜规则，不成文的规定，就是你绝对不能出卖任何人。如果你因为某事被抓，如果你参与其中，你就得默默承受。那是做一个男人的分内事。
So I looked at him and of course I said, well, I didn't do it. But I wasn't going to say who did it and I didn't say Billy Burns was lying. I got a beating that night anyway. And then the next day in school, the nuns took us all in and was questioning us. And I could-- it would have been easy for me to say, I didn't do it. It was Billy. But instead, I sucked it up because I knew if I thought that those zebra stripes were bad, the beaten I would have received from my dad would have been triple-- giving people up. So I was expelled from school, and that was my first lesson in being the fall guy, taking the rap for something I didn't do.
所以我看着他，当然我说，我没干。但我不会说出是谁干的，我也没有说比利·伯恩斯在撒谎。那天晚上我还是挨了一顿打。第二天在学校里，修女把我们都叫去盘问。我当时完全可以说，不是我干的，是比利。那样会很容易。但我选择了默默承受，因为我知道，如果我觉得那些“斑马条纹”已经够疼了，那我爸因为我出卖别人而打我的力度会是那的三倍。所以我被学校开除了，那是我第一次学到做替罪羊，为我没做过的事背黑锅。
Well, today on our program, the Fall Guy, stories of people who take the fall out of principle, and people who take the fall because they just can't figure out any way to get out of it. In other words, willing and unwilling fall guys.
今天在我们的节目中，《替罪羊》，讲述了人们出于原则背黑锅，以及人们因为想不出任何办法脱身而背黑锅的故事。换句话说，有心甘情愿的替罪羊，也有身不由己的替罪羊。
Our program today in four acts. Act one, Beat It. Act two, Be Careful Who You Love. Act three, Don't Stop 'til You Get Enough. Act four, Man in the Mirror. In this four acts, it's Mike Birbiglia, Philip Gourevitch, the Planet Money guys and Shalom Auslander. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目分为四幕。第一幕，《走开》。第二幕，《小心你爱的人》。第三幕，《不满足就别停下》。第四幕，《镜中人》。这四幕的主角分别是迈克·比尔比利亚（Mike Birbiglia）、菲利普·古雷维奇（Philip Gourevitch）、《Planet Money》的团队以及沙洛姆·奥斯兰德（Shalom Auslander）。请留在我们身边。
"Act one, Beat It."
“第一幕，《走开》。”
Sometimes things start happening to you, and then they keep happening to you, and it's only once days and weeks have passed that you realize exactly what it is that's going on. That's what happened to Mike Birbiglia. He recorded this story in front of an audience in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
有时事情开始发生在你身上，然后接二连三地发生，直到过了好几天甚至几周，你才意识到到底发生了什么。这就是迈克·比尔比利亚的遭遇。他在马萨诸塞州剑桥市的一场演出中录制了这个故事。
When I was a freshman in high school I went to an all boys' Catholic school called St. John's in Shrewsbury, Massachusetts. And the first few weeks of school are pretty overwhelming because there are kids from all different towns: Shrewsbury, Worcester, Sutton, Oxford, Milford, Leominster, Milford.
我上高一时，去了一所名叫圣约翰（St. John's）的全男子天主教学校，在马萨诸塞州的什鲁斯伯里。开学前几周压力非常大，因为那儿的学生来自各个不同的城镇：什鲁斯伯里、伍斯特、萨顿、牛津、米尔福德、莱明斯特、米尔福德。
One of the things about all boys' schools is that homophobia is almost a religion as opposed to usually where it's just an integral part of a religion. We were constantly calling each other gay. A common conversation would be like, you're gay. No, you are. No, you are. And that would go on for like an hour.
全男子学校的一个特点是，恐同几乎成了一种宗教，而不是像通常那样仅仅是某种宗教的组成部分。我们不停地骂对方是同性恋。常见的对话就像是，你是同性恋。不，你才是。不，你才是。这种对话能持续整整一个小时。
And every day when we walked down the hill to soccer practice there was a back and forth between the soccer and football teams that the other team was in fact, gay. And what developed was this kind of all out you're gay war.
每天我们下山去参加足球训练时，足球队和橄榄球队之间都会互骂对方其实是同性恋。结果演变成了一场全面爆发的“你是同性恋”大战。
I found out later that one of my you're gay grenades hit a guy named Joey [? Grigione ?]. Now I didn't know Joey [? Grigione ?], but he was from Worcester. He was tough. He liked to fight. This is going to sound like I'm making this up, but he was like a cross between a white Allen Iverson and a velociraptor.
我后来发现，我的其中一颗“你是同性恋”手榴弹砸中了一个名叫乔伊·格里乔内（Joey Grigione）的家伙。当时我不认识乔伊·格里乔内，但他来自伍斯特。他很强硬。他喜欢打架。这听起来可能像是我编的，但他就像白人版的阿伦·艾弗森（Allen Iverson）和迅猛龙的结合体。
So one day I'm walking down the hill to soccer practice and I'm hit by what feels like a rock on the back of my head. I later found out that it was a fist. Forgot to mention this detail: Joey had rock-like fists. The impact of this immediately knocks me to the ground and I'm on the ground. I'm being hit by these rock fists. And finally, I'm like, I need to run away.
所以有一天我下山去参加足球训练，突然感觉后脑勺挨了一块石头。我后来才知道那是一记拳头。忘了提一个细节：乔伊的拳头硬得像石头。冲击力瞬间把我击倒在地，我趴在地上。我被这些石头般的拳头殴打着。最后，我想，我得逃走。
I don't even consider fighting back. I'm just like, I need to leave here. This is going terribly. This is the worst walk ever. So he hits me about four or five times. Mind you, he's in full football gear and I am in nylon shorts and shin guards. So if he had wanted to beat the crap out of my shins, no dice. But really, anywhere else on my body is fair game. Particularly my head, which he seemed focused on.
我根本没想过还手。我只是想，我得离开这儿。这太糟糕了。这是有史以来最糟的步行。他大概打了我四五下。请注意，他穿着全套橄榄球装备，而我穿着尼龙短裤和护腿板。所以如果他想把我的小腿踢烂，那是不可能的。但说真的，我身体的其他部位都是活靶子。尤其是我的头，他似乎特别专注那里。
I run down the hill and he shouts, now who's gay? And he was right. In that context between me and him, I was definitely the one who was gay.
我跑下山，他大喊道，现在谁是同性恋？他是对的。在这种情况下，我和他之间，我绝对是那个“同性恋”。
But it's at this point that I realize that Joey [? Grigione ?] actually cared that someone had called him gay. That's what confused me. It never occurred to me that it had any meaning to call anything, anyone gay. I mean, we called everything gay. The football team, some of our teachers, the water fountain, geometry, tuna fish sandwiches. I mean, anything.
但就在这时，我意识到乔伊·格里乔内居然真的在意别人叫他同性恋。这让我很困惑。我从没想过叫任何人或任何东西“同性恋”会有什么意义。我的意思是，我们把一切都叫作同性恋。橄榄球队、我们的老师、饮水机、几何学、金枪鱼三明治。什么都是。
Anyway I go to practice and I tried to go on business as usual. And that day in the middle of sprints, I start crying. You know, I can't control it. And the coach asked me, what happened and I tell him. And so at this point there's an investigation. And I assume Joey [? Grigione ?] will be punished in some way. I don't know, but maybe suspended. Maybe even expelled from school. But he isn't. He's suspended for one football game.
不管怎样，我去训练了，试图装作若无其事。那天在短跑训练中，我开始哭了起来。你知道，我控制不住。教练问我发生了什么事，我就告诉了他。这下调查开始了。我以为乔伊·格里乔内会受到某种惩罚。不知道，也许是停课。甚至可能被学校开除。但他没有。他只被禁赛了一场橄榄球比赛。
There are things that kids do to each other in high school that if you did them as adults, you would go to jail for sure. If I walked up here and I said to this guy, like, you're gay, and he takes my head and smashes it on the stage, he would go to jail. Not at St. John's. One football game. Which I thought was nothing, but apparently Joey was furious about this.
孩子们在高中里对彼此做的事情，如果是在成年人之间，肯定要坐牢。如果我走到这里对这家伙说，你这个同性恋，然后他把我的头抓起来砸在舞台上，他肯定会去坐牢。但在圣约翰学校就不会。只是一场橄榄球比赛。我觉得这根本不算什么，但显然乔伊对此非常愤怒。
So he sends some other bullies after me because they're watching him at this point. And one day I'm walking back from soccer practice and this guy named Tom [? Bocatti ?] walks up to me and he gets in my face. But there's nothing really to argue about. Because the original fight was based on nothing. It was like, you're never going to call Joey [? Grigione ?] gay again or I'll kill you. And I was like, absolutely. You have my word, fine sir.
于是他派了一些别的霸凌者来找我麻烦，因为他们现在都在盯着我。有一天我从足球训练回来，这个名叫汤姆·博卡蒂（Tom Bocatti）的家伙走到我面前，把脸凑过来。但其实没什么可争论的。因为最初的冲突根本毫无根据。就像是，你再也不许叫乔伊·格里乔内同性恋，否则我就杀了你。我回答说，绝对没问题。我向您保证，好先生。
One day I'm at my locker and this guy Bill Murphy goes, hey, Mike. And I look over and he punches me in the face. Not really hard, but hard enough that it made the punch in the face noise, which is pride swallowing. And he goes, that's for Joey [? Grigione ?]. And I'm like, what! Wait a minute, this guy is smaller than me. And what's sad is I don't even fight back. I'm like, I guess this is what my life is like now.
有一天我在储物柜前，那个叫比尔·墨菲（Bill Murphy）的家伙过来喊，嘿，迈克。我转头看过去，他一拳打在我脸上。不是特别重，但足以发出那种“挨拳头”的声音，那真是丢脸透了。他说，这是替乔伊·格里乔内给你的。我心想，什么！等一下，这家伙比我还小。可悲的是，我连还手都没还。我想，看来我以后的生活就是这样了。
And the next day I'm in the computer lab and I'm writing an article for the school paper about the aviation club and this guy walks in and he goes, Dave Kilroy's looking for you and he's going to kill you. And I'm like, I don't even know who Dave Kilroy is. That's how bad my situation was. I'm the kind of person who, for fun, writes articles called, "Aviation Club Soars Into Orbit." And a bully I have never heard of is sending out envoys.
第二天我在计算机实验室，正在为校报写一篇关于航空俱乐部的文章，那个家伙走进来，说，戴夫·基尔罗伊（Dave Kilroy）在找你，他要杀了你。我想，我甚至不知道戴夫·基尔罗伊是谁。我的处境有多糟可见一斑。我是一个闲暇时会写题为《航空俱乐部翱翔天际》这种文章的人，而一个我闻所未闻的恶霸居然派出了信使。
One more thing that made this entirely strange, and this might just be funny for me, but there was a dress code at the school. And so in the middle of all this violence everyone is wearing a coat and tie. So these bullies, they look like these low rent child mobsters sent in to discipline people on bad loans.
还有一件事让这整件事变得极其怪异，可能只有我觉得好笑，学校有严格的着装要求。所以在这暴力重重之中，每个人都穿着西装打着领带。这些恶霸看起来就像是被派去追讨坏账的低级黑帮小童。
Well, I make it through the winter and I decide that I'm going to stick it out. Like all great underdogs, I'd been knocked down, but I was going to make a place for myself. So I run for class president. And I lose by a lot. And then, I try out for the tennis team. And I don't make it-- by a lot.
好吧，我熬过了冬天，决定坚持下去。像所有伟大的弱者一样，我虽然被打倒了，但我还是要争取自己的一席之地。所以我竞选班长。结果输得很惨。然后，我又参加网球队选拔。没选上——差距很大。
St. John's just didn't want to participate in my life. And at the end of the year I came up with a different idea, which was to quit. And I ran this by all the adults in my life: my teachers, my parents, my guidance counselor. And what's surprising is that no one tried to talk me out of it. They didn't say those things that you hear in the after school specials. Like, hey, buddy, don't give up. And stick it out champ. Or, don't let them get the best of you, ace.
圣约翰学校就是不欢迎我加入他们的生活。年底时我有了个新想法，就是退学。我把这事跟生活中所有的成年人都商量了：我的老师、父母、升学辅导员。令人惊讶的是，没有人试图劝我放弃。他们没有说那种你在课后特辑里听到的漂亮话。比如，嘿，伙计，别放弃。加油，冠军。或者，别让他们打倒你，王牌。
The best of me was off the table, and everyone knew it. Somehow I'd become the fall guy for the entire ninth grade class. I symbolized a certain kind of kid, the kind of kid who everyone hates. So I left.
我自己最好的那部分已经无处发挥，大家也都心知肚明。不知怎么的，我成了整个九年级的替罪羊。我象征着某种特定的孩子，那种人人都讨厌的孩子。于是我离开了。
And at my new school, those first few weeks where everyone's getting to know each other, where you're from, what do you like to do, I decided to omit the fact that at my previous school for a year I had been picked on so badly that I left the school.
在新学校，大家还在互相认识的头几周，问你来自哪里、喜欢干什么的时候，我决定隐瞒自己在上一所学校因为被欺负得太惨而不得不退学的事实。
And here's the truth about life that they never tell you in those after school specials. Running away works.
关于生活，真相是那些课后特辑永远不会告诉你：逃避确实有用。
Because you know what? The kids at my new school, they never found out.
因为你知道吗？新学校的孩子们从来没发现真相。
Mike Birbiglia, who starts a national tour in August, going through the Fall from Cape Cod to Los Angeles. Search the Internet for his name for details.
迈克·比尔比利亚，将于八月开始全国巡演，从秋季开始从科德角巡演到洛杉矶。在网上搜索他的名字获取详情。
[MUSIC- "RUNNIN' AWAY" BY SLY AND THE FAMILY STONE]
[音乐-斯莱和斯通家族乐队的《RUNNIN' AWAY》]
"Act two, Be Careful Who You Love."
“第二幕，《小心你爱的人》。”
We now turn to a political fall guy, somebody who got blamed all over the world for certain US policies. Somebody that you definitely heard of, but who hasn't made much of a case for herself. Journalist Philip Gourevitch tells her story.
现在我们转向一位政治替罪羊，一个因为美国的某些政策在全世界饱受指责的人。一个你肯定听说过，但自己却没怎么为自己辩护过的人。记者菲利普·古雷维奇讲述了她的故事。
There's no law of nature, or even of storytelling that says a fall guy has to be admirable. Just because the wrong person is blamed for something doesn't mean that person's otherwise blameless. I mean, as a rule, a fall guy is not going to be someone who's made all the right choices.
自然界或讲故事的法则中，都没有说替罪羊必须是一个令人钦佩的人。仅仅因为某人被错误地指责了某件事，并不代表她本人就没有过错。我的意思是，通常情况下，替罪羊不一定是个做出了所有正确选择的人。
Private First Class Lynndie England was 20 years old when she was sent to Iraq in 2003 in the first summer of the war. She was a West Virginia girl, a reservist with the 372nd Military Police Company.
林迪·英格兰（Lynndie England）二等兵在2003年战争的第一个夏天被派往伊拉克时才20岁。她是个来自西弗吉尼亚州的女孩，是第372宪兵连的预备役人员。
At first, the unit was sent to the city of Al Hilla where they had a pretty good time. Al Hilla was calm. They could walk the streets, meet Iraqis, do some tourism. The word was that they'd be going home after a couple months. But then they get sent instead to Abu Ghraib Prison outside Baghdad.
起初，部队被派往阿尔希拉（Al Hilla）市，那里的日子还过得不错。阿尔希拉很平静。他们可以走在街上，接触伊拉克人，做点旅游观光。当时的传言是他们几个月后就能回家。但后来他们却被派到了巴格达郊外的阿布格莱布（Abu Ghraib）监狱。
Nobody in the 372nd had any training as military prison guards, but that's the work that most of Lynndie England's best buddies were given. England herself was luckier, she was in administration. Officially she wasn't even allowed on the cell blocks. Her job was in-processing.
第372连里没人受过军事监狱看守的训练，但这就是林迪·英格兰最好的伙伴们被分配的工作。英格兰本人比较幸运，她在行政部门。按规定，她甚至不被允许进入囚室区域。她的工作是入狱登记。
American combat troops were rounding up Iraqis by the hundreds every day and dumping them in Abu Ghraib. England took their fingerprints. She did their retina scans and looked after their paperwork. In-processing had been her job in the unit back in the states too.
美国作战部队每天抓捕数百名伊拉克人，并将他们扔进阿布格莱布监狱。英格兰负责记录他们的指纹。她负责他们的视网膜扫描，还要处理文书工作。入狱登记在部队还在美国时也是她的工作。
The year before when the company was on a drill weekend, getting ready to be activated and sent to Iraq, a new guy joined up, Corporal Charles Graner. An ex marine, he'd served in the first Gulf War.
前一年，当部队在训练周末准备激活并派往伊拉克时，一个新人加入了，下士查尔斯·格拉纳（Charles Graner）。他曾是一名海军陆战队员，参加过第一次海湾战争。
England took his papers and in-processed him. Beyond that, she says, she hardly noticed Graner at first. But then she realized he noticed her.
英格兰处理了他的文件，帮他完成了入狱登记。除此之外，她说，起初她几乎没注意到格拉纳。但后来她意识到他注意到了她。
He would follow me around he said. Like I smoked and he didn't. He started smoking, so he could get out there in the little smokers group. So he could talk to me. England wasn't used that kind of attention. And looking back, she said, he played me.
他会跟着我，她说。比如我抽烟而他不抽。他开始抽烟，这样就能混进那个小烟民团体。这样他就能跟我说话。英格兰不习惯那种关注。回顾往事，她说，他玩弄了我。
He courted her with Bluegrass music, her favorite. He bought her clothes and drinks and meals. He taught her how to drive a stick shift. She'd never seen the ocean before, so Graner took her to Virginia Beach. The thing was, Lynndie England was married. That held her back for a while, but she felt stress and disconnection at home. And everything in her marriage was made worse by the fact that she was about to be deployed to Iraq. She talked to Graner about it and he listened. She'd say, I don't need this. And he'd say, well, no, you don't. She'd say of her husband, we're just friends. And Graner would say it back to her. When she said, we're not really compatible as husband and wife, Graner would return it as, you're not really compatible as husband and wife. And England found this steady echo persuasive.
他用她最爱的蓝草音乐追求她。他给她买衣服、买饮料、请吃饭。他教她开手动挡的车。她以前从没见过大海，所以格拉纳带她去了弗吉尼亚海滩。问题是，林迪·英格兰当时已婚。这让她犹豫了一段时间，但她在家里感到压力和疏离感。而她正要被派往伊拉克的事实让她的婚姻生活更加糟糕。她跟格拉纳谈过这些，他是个倾听者。她说，我不想要这样。他说，好吧，确实不应该。她说起自己的丈夫，我们只是朋友。格拉纳就跟她学舌。当她说，我们作为夫妻确实不合拍，格拉纳就回赠说，你们作为夫妻确实不合拍。英格兰觉得这种稳定的回声很有说服力。
Graner, she said, he's really charming. And I was what? 20 years old when I met him. He was 34.
格拉纳，她说，他真的很迷人。我那时才多少岁？遇见他时我才20岁。他34岁。
When they got together, she didn't mind that he took pictures of her all the time. Even, when he insisted, naked pictures. England filed for separation from her husband and told him she wanted a divorce. It was a heady spring for England with the invasion on TV, waiting to go to war, and love.
当他们在一起时，她并不介意他一直给她拍照。甚至当他坚持要拍裸照时。英格兰向丈夫提出了分居，并告诉他她想要离婚。那对英格兰来说是个令人眩晕的春天，电视上播放着入侵新闻，等待着奔赴战场，还有爱情。
England and Graner had been a couple for six months when they arrived at Abu Ghraib. Graner documented their whole romance on his digital camera. After the first Gulf War, he told her, nobody had believed his war stories. And this time he was going to have proof. He was never without his camera and that's what he told everyone. He was collecting proof.
英格兰和格拉纳在到达阿布格莱布时已经交往了六个月。格拉纳用他的数码相机记录了他们的整段恋情。他告诉她，第一次海湾战争后，没人相信他的战争故事。这一次，他要留下证据。他随时随地都带着相机，这就是他告诉所有人的话。他在收集证据。
At Abu Ghraib, Graner was the guard in charge of the night shift on the cell blocks reserved for so-called high value prisoners who were being interrogated by military intelligence and the CIA.
在阿布格莱布，格拉纳是夜班守卫负责人，负责看管那些所谓的“高价值”囚犯，他们正接受军事情报部门和中央情报局（CIA）的审讯。
While he was there, he wound up taking many photographs of American soldiers abusing their Iraqi wards. Graner posed in a lot of those photographs himself, and he posed England in a lot of them. There were hundreds of photographs from Abu Ghraib. But the pictures that became instantly iconic were the ones that showed naked prisoners in the same frame with American servicewomen. Most famously, or infamously, they were the shots of Lynndie England holding what looked like a leash at the end of which crawled a naked Iraqi man.
他在那里的时候，最终拍摄了许多美军士兵虐待伊拉克囚犯的照片。格拉纳本人在很多照片中摆拍，他也让英格兰在很多照片中摆拍。阿布格莱布有成百上千张照片。但那些瞬间成为偶像的照片，是那些裸体囚犯和美国女兵出现在同一画面中的照片。最著名，或者说臭名昭著的，是林迪·英格兰拿着看起来像绳子的东西，另一头爬着一个裸体伊拉克男人的照片。
And the shots from another night, of England pointing and grinning at a naked and hooded prisoner who'd been made to masturbate in front of her. These scenes had obviously been staged for the camera. England, staring flatly in the lens, or giving a thumbs up, is clearly posing for the photographer.
还有另一晚的照片，英格兰指着一个裸体、头被蒙住的囚犯咧嘴大笑，那个囚犯被迫在她面前自慰。这些场景显然是为相机导演的。英格兰平视镜头，或是竖起大拇指，显然是在为摄影师摆拍。
The Abu Ghraib photographs eventually exposed the Bush administration's torture policy to the world. But the repellent, kinky weirdness of the images, of Lynndie England and her naked captives, created an immediate and powerful distraction.
阿布格莱布的照片最终向全世界揭露了布什政府的虐囚政策。但林迪·英格兰和她那些裸体俘虏所呈现出的那种令人作呕、变态离奇的画面，制造了一种直接而强有力的干扰。
Lynndie England was portrayed in the press as a sadist, a masochist, an Appalachian hillbilly slut, mentally retarded, you name it. Everybody had an opinion about her. But there was one thing missing from the discussion: her voice.
媒体将林迪·英格兰刻画成一个施虐狂、受虐狂、阿巴拉契亚山区的乡下荡妇、弱智，随便什么词都行。每个人对她都有看法。但讨论中缺少了一样东西：她的声音。
The army placed all the soldiers who took and appeared in the Abu Ghraib photographs in custody, then sent to courts marshal. These were the only people ever to be convicted and imprisoned for the president's torture program, and none of them was of high rank than staff sergeant. They never had the opportunity to speak for themselves in public until they began to be released a year, or two, or three later. That's when the filmmaker, Errol Morris, started interviewing them for a documentary movie. And I joined him to write a book from the same material.
军方将所有拍摄和出现在阿布格莱布照片中的士兵拘留，随后送上军事法庭。这些人是唯一因为总统的虐囚计划而被定罪和监禁的人，而且他们之中没人超过参谋军士军衔。在他们被释放一、两或三年后，他们才有机会公开为自己说话。那时，电影制作人埃罗尔·莫里斯（Errol Morris）开始为一部纪录片采访他们。我也加入了他，用同样的素材写了一本书。
Lynndie England spoke for nearly nine hours over two days. She didn't feel guilty. In fact, she didn't think she'd done anything wrong. She kept saying, everything we did was just what we were told to do. It was true. The MPs weren't only instructed and encouraged to harm the prisoners in the ways they recorded in pictures, they were commended for it.
林迪·英格兰在两天内谈了近九个小时。她不觉得自己有罪。事实上，她不认为自己做错了任何事。她一直在说，我们所做的一切都只是被告知要做的事。这是事实。宪兵们不仅被指示并鼓励以照片中记录的方式伤害囚犯，他们还因此受到了表彰。
There were senior commanders coming through the cell blocks pretty much every night to watch the MPs do their dirty work. As Graner took photos of what was going on, he showed them to his superior officers at the prison. Their response was, good job. He even got that in writing from his captain after he knocked one prisoner's head into the wall. So hard that eight stitches were required to staunch the bleeding.
几乎每天晚上都有高级指挥官巡视囚室，观看宪兵干那些肮脏的勾当。当格拉纳拍摄正在发生的事情时，他会把照片展示给监狱里的长官看。他们的反应是，“干得好”。在他把一名囚犯的头撞向墙壁之后，他甚至从连长那里得到了书面嘉奖。那次撞击导致囚犯缝了八针才止住血。
Again and again, the MPs were told, these prisoners are the worst of the worst. And as England kept saying, the stuff you see in the photographs is not the real torture that was happening at the prison. What you see is just humiliation, she said, and harassment.
宪兵们一次又一次被告知，这些囚犯是罪犯中的罪犯。正如英格兰一直所说，照片中看到的那些并不是监狱里发生的真正酷刑。她说，你看到的只是羞辱和骚扰。
That same Fall at Abu Ghraib, soldiers were shooting prisoners who protested the rotten food and overcrowding at Abu Ghraib. Shooting them with live rounds. In some cases, shooting them dead. A prisoner was killed during a CIA interrogation in the shower and Graner and his team were enlisted to help cover it up.
就在阿布格莱布的那个秋天，士兵们开枪打死了那些抗议监狱食物腐烂和过度拥挤的囚犯。用实弹射击。在某些情况下，当场射杀。一名囚犯在中央情报局的淋浴间审讯中死亡，格拉纳和他的团队被招募去帮忙掩盖。
There was a night when England heard a prisoner screaming in that shower, a scream so horribly piercing that she was sure he was being killed. So she couldn't get too worked up about the photographs, and she expressed no remorse for her conduct at Abu Ghraib. She was just a bystander there, the night watchman's girlfriend, just lending him a hand with his chores. That's how she saw it. And it made it tough to feel sympathy for her.
有一天晚上，英格兰听到淋浴间里有囚犯在尖叫，那尖叫声极其刺耳，她确信他正在被杀害。所以她无法对那些照片感到太纠结，她对自己在阿布格莱布的行为也没有表现出悔意。她只是那里的一个旁观者，夜班看守的女朋友，只是帮他处理点杂事而已。她就是这么看的。这让她很难让人同情。
England fit nobody's political narrative. Not the left's, not the right's. It wasn't even clear that she disapproved of the policy for which she had taken the fall.
英格兰谁的政治叙事都不符合。左派的不符合，右派的也不符合。甚至不清楚她是否反对她因此而背黑锅的政策。
Take, for instance, the picture which showed her with a naked prisoner on a leash. It wasn't actually a dog leash, it was a cargo tie down strap that Graner used to coax a belligerent prisoner out of an isolation cell. And Graner had handed it to her for all of 30 seconds so he could photograph her with it. Here's what England said when she looked at the photograph.
比如，那张她牵着裸体囚犯的照片。那其实不是狗链，那是格拉纳用来诱导一个好战囚犯走出隔离室的货运捆绑带。格拉纳把它递给她，只让她拿了30秒，以便给她拍照。这是英格兰看着那张照片时说的话。
I don't see the infamous picture from the Iraqi War. I just see me. It's just the picture.
我没看到伊拉克战争那张臭名昭著的照片。我只看到了我自己。它就只是一张照片。
The first thing that comes up in my mind is just, that's me. And yeah, that happened at the prison when I was in Iraq and that was one of the pictures taken.
脑海中浮现的第一件事就是，那是我。是的，那是在伊拉克监狱里发生的事，那是拍下的照片之一。
As far as she was concerned, it wasn't a snapshot of her relationship to the prisoner, it was a snapshot of her relationship with Graner.
对她而言，这不是她与囚犯关系的快照，而是她与格拉纳关系的快照。
It's showing that he has power over me. And he wanted to demonstrate that power.
这显示出他对我有控制权。他想展示那种控制权。
At Abu Ghraib, Charles Graner had become Lynndie England's chain of command. Whatever he asked me to do, she said, I'd do it.
在阿布格莱布，查尔斯·格拉纳成了林迪·英格兰的指挥链。她说，无论他让我做什么，我都会做。
For her, this story isn't about torture, it's a love story. In the end, Graner moved on from England while they were still at Abu Ghraib. This was a month or two before she found out she was pregnant with his baby. He cut her loose and took up instead with another soldier from the unit, Megan Ambuhl. They're married now, Chuck and Megan Graner. Although he's still in custody serving a 10 year sentence.
对她来说，这个故事不是关于酷刑的，这是一个爱情故事。最终，格拉纳在他们还在阿布格莱布时就移情别恋了。这是她发现自己怀上他孩子的一两个月前。他甩了她，转而和连里的另一个士兵梅根·安布尔（Megan Ambuhl）在一起。他们现在结婚了，查克和梅根·格拉纳。虽然他还在服刑，被判了10年。
When England looks at how it all turned out between them, she understands that she was duped by a government that made torture its policy and then punished those who let themselves be seen doing it. Just like a decoy she said. But mostly, she sees herself as duped by Graner.
当英格兰回顾他们之间的一切结局时，她明白自己被政府愚弄了，政府将酷刑定为政策，然后惩罚那些让自己被拍到干这些事的人。她说，就像个诱饵。但主要是，她觉得自己被格拉纳愚弄了。
The moment that changed me was meeting Graner. If I wasn't involved with Graner I wouldn't probably be here. I wouldn't have been in that situation. I probably would have been doing admin work. Therefore, I wouldn't have been in the pictures. I wouldn't have been involved in any of that. I probably would have know it was going on, but I wouldn't have been involved and I wouldn't have therefore, went to prison. Or been the poster girl for this war.
改变我的一刻是遇见格拉纳。如果我没和格拉纳扯上关系，我现在大概不会在这里。我本不会陷入那种境地。我可能还在做行政工作。因此，我不会出现在照片里。我也不会参与任何那种事。我大概会知道有这种事，但我不会参与，因此我也不会进监狱。或者成为这场战争的海报女孩。
How do people see me as the villain? I mean, yeah, I was in pictures that showed me holding a leash around the guy's neck. But that's all I did. I was in a picture. I never actually did anything to them. I was convicted of being in a picture.
人们怎么会把我视为恶棍？我的意思是，是的，我出现在那些显示我抓着狗链勒着那个男人脖子的照片里。但这就是我干的一切。我出现在照片里。我从未真正对他们做过什么。我因为出现在照片里而被定罪。
Lynndie England's living back with her mom and her stepdad now with no income and with her three year old boy Carter, whose only relationship to his father is that he looks more like Graner every day.
林迪·英格兰现在和她妈妈以及继父住在一起，没有收入，带着她三岁的儿子卡特，那孩子的父亲唯一与他有关联的就是他长得越来越像格拉纳。
I just want to go on with life. Get a job, raise my son. It's going to be hard for me to get a job because now I have a felony on my record. Plus that people don't want the publicity. I don't think I have a lot of choices. The way I feel right now in my own country to walk down the street is, I'm still scared. Because there's just people that hate me. They feel like we shouldn't have been doing that or we were being inhumane, or whatever their opinion is. At least when I was in Iraq I knew who the enemy was. Here I don't.
我只想继续生活。找份工作，养大儿子。因为我有犯罪记录，找工作会很难。再加上人们不想要这种曝光。我不认为我有很多选择。现在我在自己的国家走在街上，我感到害怕。因为有人恨我。他们觉得我们本不该那样做，或者我们表现得不人道，不管他们的观点是什么。至少在伊拉克时我知道敌人是谁。在这里我不知道。
I mean I go out. I go to Walmart, I go shopping. But it's like I'm always watching my back. I don't like to walk in public. I don't like to walk down the street. I don't like to walk into a room that's crowded because it feels like everyone's staring at me. And people do. They stare me when I'm shopping for food, or something. I got my son with me and I'm concentrating on him. But I know people are staring at me. They know it's me. All I did was what I was told to do. I didn't make the war. I can't end the war. It just doesn't make sense. The government is just putting the blame on me because they can, and they have. I'm over it. I'm fine. You know, I'm not fine with it, but whatever.
我是指我会出门。我会去沃尔玛，去购物。但就像我总是在提防背后。我不喜欢在公共场合走路。我不喜欢走在街上。我不喜欢走进拥挤的房间，因为感觉每个人都在盯着我。人们确实会盯着我看。当我买菜或者干什么的时候，他们会盯着我。我带着儿子，注意力都在他身上。但我知道人们在盯着我。他们知道是我。我所做的只是被告知要做的事。不是我发起的战争。我不能结束战争。这根本说不通。政府只是把责任推给我，因为他们能，而且他们已经这么做了。我不去想了。我很好。你知道，我并不好，但随它去吧。
She doesn't like to remember Abu Ghraib, but it's hard work forgetting.
她不喜欢回想阿布格莱布，但要忘记很难。
When a memory comes over her she says she thinks about something else, reads a book, watches a movie Sometimes she has nightmares.
她说，当记忆袭来时，她会想点别的，看本书，看部电影。有时她会做噩梦。
I don't even talk to my psychiatrist about them.
我甚至都不和我的精神科医生谈论这些。
Really?
真的吗？
No. Because if I don't think about it, then guess what? Thoughts cause emotions. If I don't think about it, I'm not going to relive it. I'm only going to feel what I feel then. I'm not going to feel anything. So that's what I do, I don't think about anything. I don't want to relive or feel. If I think about it, I mean, it's overwhelming. It's too much to think about. It's why I take medicine, so I don't have the nightmares. Anti-depression, anxiety pills. That and usually my son wears me out. I'm usually exhausted and go to sleep. On the rare occasion that I forget to take my medicine, I usually have nightmares.
不。因为如果我不去想，猜猜会怎样？思想会引发情绪。如果我不去想，我就不会重温那种经历。我只会感受当时的感觉。我什么都不会感觉到。所以我就是这样做，我不去想任何事。我不想重温或感受。如果我想到它，那真是无法承受。思绪太多了。这就是为什么我吃药，这样就不会做噩梦。抗抑郁和抗焦虑药。除此之外，通常我儿子会把我耗尽。我通常筋疲力尽就睡着了。偶尔忘了吃药时，我通常会做噩梦。
When that guy was screaming in the shower, I'll hear that in the middle of the night. It'll wake me up and freak me out. I mean, the way he was screaming. It sounded like they were killing him. Just death scream I guess you could call it.
那个家伙在淋浴间尖叫时，我在半夜还会听到那个声音。那会把我惊醒并吓坏我。我的意思是，他尖叫的方式。听起来就像他们正在杀他。我想你可以称之为临终尖叫。
Sorry?
抱歉？
Like a death scream, I don't know. It was horrible. He was just screaming at the top of his lungs constantly. And you're right like in the next room. It's like it's vibrating your whole body it's so loud. I don't think I'll ever get that out of my head.
就像临终尖叫，我不知道。那太可怕了。他只是不停地扯着嗓子大喊。而他就住在隔壁房间。尖叫声太响了，仿佛让你的整个身体都在震动。我想我永远无法把它从脑海中抹去。
In spite of the nightmares, when she spoke of the lessons she took away from Abu Ghraib, England went right back to Graner.
尽管有噩梦，但当谈到她从阿布格莱布吸取的教训时，英格兰又回到了格拉纳身上。
Learn from your mistakes. I learned from mine. It's like, I don't need a man to survive. Forget him.
吃一堑长一智。我从自己的错误中吸取了教训。就是这样，我不需要男人也能活下去。忘了他吧。
This is what makes Lynndie England such a frustrating fall guy, her inability to see Abu Ghraib as anything more than the place where she met her own private fate. Yet, the more she talked, the more I came to see her point.
这就是为什么林迪·英格兰是个如此让人沮丧的替罪羊，她无法将阿布格莱布视为除她个人命运之外的任何地方。然而，她谈得越多，我就越理解她的观点。
She'd gone off to war, proud to be a soldier, and she returned a figure of disgrace on a scale that is really utterly incomprehensible. Her buddies from Abu Ghraib had also been scapegoated. But Lynndie England was the household name. Politicians denounced her, newscasters sneered at her, she got hate mail blaming her for the fact that Americans were being beheaded by Iraqi insurgents. And around the world, her picture holding the leash was splashed on the walls of mosques, stenciled on protest t-shirts, hoisted on signs that bobbed over angry mobs from Tehran to Jakarta. So she couldn't make sense of what all this had to do with her. Can you blame her? I mean, at one level, she's right.
她曾去参战，为成为一名士兵而自豪，而她回国后却成了一个规模极其难以理解的耻辱人物。她在阿布格莱布的伙伴们也成了替罪羊。但林迪·英格兰却成了家喻户晓的名字。政客谴责她，新闻主播嘲讽她，她收到的仇恨邮件指责她导致了美国人被伊拉克叛乱分子斩首。而在世界各地，她牵着狗链的照片被涂鸦在清真寺的墙上，印在抗议的T恤上，高举在从德黑兰到雅加达愤怒人群上方的标语牌上。所以她无法理解这一切和她有什么关系。你能怪她吗？我的意思是，从某种层面来看，她是对的。
Philip Gourevitch. His book about what happened in that prison and in those photos is called, The Ballad of Abu Ghraib. Errol Morris's film with the actual interviews with England and the other US personnel from the prison is just really this incredible piece of filmmaking. I cannot recommend it enough. View movies are as ambitious and eye-opening. It's called, Standard Operating Procedure.
菲利普·古雷维奇。他关于那座监狱和那些照片中发生的事情的书名叫《阿布格莱布的歌谣》。埃罗尔·莫里斯拍摄的纪录片，采访了监狱里的英格兰和其他美国人员，真的是一部令人难以置信的电影作品。我极力推荐。看看这些雄心勃勃、令人大开眼界的电影。它叫《标准作业程序》。
Coming up, grandma takes the fall. Or that's what a little grandkid wants anyway. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，祖母背黑锅。或者那是小孙子想要的。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, the Fall Guy. We have stories of people who are taking the rap for things they were not responsible for, willingly or unwillingly.
这是《This American Life》，我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目是《替罪羊》。我们要讲的是那些心甘情愿或身不由己地为自己不负责任的事情背黑锅的人的故事。
We have arrived at act three of our show. "Act three, Don't Stop 'til You Get Enough."
我们已经到了节目的第三幕。“第三幕，《不满足就别停下》。”
Our current economic crisis has moved into the beginning of a lawsuit phase. I don't know if that's good or bad. But we're in a situation where people are trying to get somebody else to take the blame, take the fall, and pay up for our financial misdeeds in the last few years. Our economics correspondents on our program, Alex Blumberg and NPR's Adam Davidson have been looking into this and they have counted so far 196 lawsuits that are simply banks suing other banks. And they have brought some of their findings here into the studio.
我们当前的经济危机已经进入了诉讼阶段。我不知道这是好是坏。但我们现在的处境是，人们正试图让别人来承担责任、背黑锅，并为我们过去几年的金融不端行为买单。我们节目的经济通讯员亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）和NPR的亚当·戴维森（Adam Davidson）一直在研究这个问题，他们目前统计出有196起诉讼仅仅是银行起诉其他银行。他们把一些发现带到了演播室。
So, Ira, as you can see, I have a huge pile of documents in front of me. These are just a handful of the lawsuits that are going.
所以，艾拉，如你所见，我面前有一大堆文件。这只是正在进行的诉讼中的一小部分。
There's big, white binders full of boring looking papers.
那是厚厚的白色文件夹，装满了无聊的文件。
Yes, and this one right here that I took out my stack, this is M&T Bank Corp versus Gemstone CDO VII and Deutsche Bank Securities, and a handful of other people. This focuses on one CDO, one of these toxic asset--
是的，我从堆里拿出的这一份，是M&T银行公司诉Gemstone CDO VII和德意志银行证券，以及其他一些人。这聚焦于一个CDO，一种有毒资产——
Collateralized debt obligations.
担保债务凭证。
Exactly. But what they're saying is that Deutsche Bank lied. That's the allegation. They had made the original mortgage loans, and then they had created these toxic products made up of all these bundled mortgage loans. They knew that a lot of people weren't paying their mortgages. A lot of people weren't even paying the first month the mortgage was due. So M&T's allegation is Deutsche Bank knew that--
没错。但他们说的是德意志银行撒了谎。这就是指控。他们制作了原始的抵押贷款，然后创造了这些由一捆捆抵押贷款组成的有毒产品。他们知道很多人并没有支付抵押贷款。很多人甚至连抵押贷款到期的第一个月都没付。所以M&T的指控是德意志银行知道这一点——
And lied to the credit agency.
并且对信用机构撒了谎。
And lied to the credit agencies, and lied to their clients.
并且对信用机构撒了谎，还对他们的客户撒了谎。
And lied to M&T.
还对M&T撒了谎。
Now has Deutsche Bank responded?
那德意志银行有回应吗？
They have. They asked a judge to dismiss this out of hand saying let's not even hear the case. And actually, this is one of the only cases out of the hundreds of securities law cases that the judge did not dismiss. It's really hard to get one of these through.
有的。他们要求法官直接驳回，说这案子连听都不用听。事实上，在数百起证券法案件中，这是少数几起法官没有驳回的案件之一。想让其中一起进入审理程序真的很难。
So M&T bank is trying to say that Deutsche Bank should be the fall guy for this $82 million? And I understand that there's another lawsuit that you guys have been looking into, which involves Citigroup.
所以M&T银行正试图让德意志银行为这8200万美元背黑锅？我听说你们一直在研究另一起诉讼，涉及花旗集团。
Yeah, this is the big one.
是的，这是最大的一起。
And in the case of Citigroup, it isn't another bank suing Citigroup.
在花旗集团的案例中，并不是另一家银行在起诉花旗集团。
Right, it's the Citigroup shareholders suing the bank that they own shares in. And specifically, it's not all shareholders, it's a subset of shareholders. Specifically, people who bought these shares between 2004 and 2009 in that five year period. And what they're saying basically is, they wouldn't have bought them for the price they paid if Citigroup had been more honest about its financial situation. So they're saying basically, they got tricked into buying Citigroup shares at a higher price than they should have paid for them.
对，是花旗集团的股东在起诉他们持有股份的银行。具体来说，不是所有股东，是一部分股东。具体来说，是在2004年到2009年这五年期间购买这些股票的人。他们基本上在说，如果花旗集团对其财务状况更诚实一点，他们就不会以支付的价格购买这些股票。所以他们基本上是在说，他们被骗了，以比应有价格更高的价格购买了花旗集团的股票。
And what's the substance of their suit against their own company?
他们对自己公司的诉讼内容是什么？
At the heart of this complaint is that Citigroup had all these toxic assets. And it's actually the opposite of the M&T lawsuit. In the M&T lawsuit, they're saying Deutsche Bank had a crappy, toxic asset that wasn't worth anything and sold it to M&T. They cheated M&T.
这份诉状的核心是花旗集团拥有所有这些有毒资产。这实际上与M&T诉讼案恰恰相反。在M&T诉讼案中，他们说德意志银行拥有一种垃圾、有毒的资产，一文不值却卖给了M&T。他们欺骗了M&T。
This lawsuit is saying Citigroup had these crappy, toxic assets and they kept them.
这起诉讼说的是花旗集团拥有这些垃圾、有毒资产，并且留下了它们。
Because they couldn't sell them. And so what they did is they kept them on their own books and then kept on, basically doing this activity for almost a year, where they would appear to sell them, but they weren't actually selling them. They were just sort of creating an off balance sheet company that they would sell these assets to, but Citigroup still had the exposure to these assets.
因为他们卖不掉。所以他们所做的是把它们保留在自己的账目上，然后基本上进行了近一年的活动，看起来他们卖掉了，但实际上并没有。他们只是创建了一家资产负债表外的公司，将这些资产卖给它，但花旗集团仍然对这些资产承担风险。
They would create an off balance sheet company? In other words, they would create a company and then pretend to sell it to that separate company.
他们会创建一家资产负债表外的公司？换句话说，他们会创建一家公司，然后假装把它卖给那家独立的公司。
Well, they would sell it to that company, but they owned that company.
嗯，他们卖给了那家公司，但他们拥有那家公司。
Right. What they didn't tell people is that they were still responsible for that company.
对。他们没告诉人们的是，他们仍然对那家公司负责。
Allegedly.
涉嫌如此。
If that company went down, they had to come and take on all of its assets.
如果那家公司倒闭了，他们必须站出来接管其所有资产。
Allegedly.
涉嫌如此。
So that's the allegation anyway.
所以无论如何，这就是指控。
Yeah. This document, which sums up their complaint is 534 pages, and it's just one of many, many documents we have on this lawsuit. I got to say, as far as tables of contents go, I find this one really interesting.
是的。这份总结他们指控的文件有534页，这只是我们关于这起诉讼拥有的众多文件中的一份。我得说，就目录而言，我觉得这一份真的很有趣。
It sort of tells the whole story in pretty inflammatory and not very legalistic language.
它以相当激进且不太法律化的语言讲述了整个故事。
Right. So it starts off, CDOs. What CDOS are. Then it says, defaults inevitable. It goes into schemes. How to make $25 billion of subprime exposure and risks parentheses, "appear to disappear." CDO Ponzi schemes.
对。所以开头是CDO。什么是CDO。然后是“违约不可避免”。接着是阴谋。如何让250亿美元的次级抵押贷款风险“看起来消失了”。CDO庞氏骗局。
Wait, wait, wait. These are the stockholders accusing their own company of running a Ponzi scheme?
等等，等等。这些股东指控他们自己的公司经营庞氏骗局？
Yeah.
是的。
OK, so Citigroup CDO Ponzi schemes. Case one, case two, case three. And then it has the continuation and culmination of the Ponzi scheme, citigroup's falsely hedged CDOs. So it's basically alleging that they made these CDOs and then they pretended to hedge them. In other words, pretended to like, basically get insurance against them if they went wrong. But the suit alleges they didn't actually get insurance against these CDOs, so they weren't protected.
好吧，所以花旗集团CDO庞氏骗局。第一案，第二案，第三案。然后是庞氏骗局的延续和顶峰，花旗集团虚假对冲的CDO。所以它基本上指控他们制造了这些CDO，然后假装对冲它们。换句话说，假装如果它们出了问题就获得保险。但诉讼指控他们实际上并没有为这些CDO购买保险，所以他们没有受到保护。
Citigroup's disclosures were materially false and misleading, omitted material information, precluded any independent assessment of Citigroup's exposure to potential risks.
花旗集团的披露在实质上是虚假和误导性的，遗漏了重要信息，排除了对花旗集团潜在风险的任何独立评估。
Wow, these people hate Citigroup.
哇，这些人恨透了花旗集团。
Exactly. I mean this is just page three I think. It goes on for another five pages of the table of content.
没错。我想这只是第三页。目录后面还有五页。
Of the table of contents.
目录后面还有五页。
Right, exactly. Citigroup's November 2007 disclosures and valuations were still false and misleading. Still is in italics.
对，没错。花旗集团2007年11月的披露和估值仍然是虚假和误导性的。“仍然”用了斜体。
Then this is one. Citigroup's pre-November 2007, super senior-- that's a type of bond. Super senior valuations were simplistic, solipsistic, and reckless reliance on credit ratings. Quote--
然后是这个。花旗集团2007年11月前的“超级优先”——这是一种债券类型。超级优先估值是对信用评级的简单化、唯我论式和鲁莽依赖。引用——
Whoa, whoa, whoa. What was solipsistic?
哇，等等。什么是“唯我论式”？
Their pre-November 2007 valuations of these bonds that they had.
他们对所持有的这些债券在2007年11月前的估值。
Were solipsistic?
是“唯我论式”的？
And then there's the whole second part of the sentence, and this is all in italics. Read this in italics. Despite the fact that CDO prospectuses authored by Citigroup stated that such ratings were not reliable indicators of CDO value. So in other words, they relied on the very things that they were saying were not reliable.
然后句子的后半部分全部是斜体。用斜体读读这段。尽管花旗集团撰写的CDO招股书声明这些评级不是CDO价值的可靠指标。所以换句话说，他们依赖的正是他们自己说不可靠的东西。
Don't get these people mad.
别惹恼这些人。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，没错。
So when you look at the M&T lawsuit, it's something familiar to us. That's something we can understand.
所以当你看到M&T的诉讼时，这是我们熟悉的东西。那是我们可以理解的东西。
They're lying to somebody about--
他们在对某人撒谎，关于——
They're lying to someone. They're cheating. The Citigroup lawsuit is actually much stranger. But it turns out, much more important. The shareholders' lawsuit to Citigroup is not that you defrauded someone else, it's that you defrauded yourself. That you brought yourself down. This by the way, is part of Citigroup's defense.
他们在对某人撒谎。他们在作弊。花旗集团的诉讼实际上要奇怪得多。但结果证明，重要得多。股东对花旗集团的诉讼不是你欺诈了别人，而是你欺诈了你自己。是你自己导致了自己的倒台。顺便说一句，这是花旗集团辩护的一部分。
In their legal documents they say, wait a second. Why in the world would we defraud ourselves?
在他们的法律文件中，他们说，等一下。我们为什么要欺诈自己？
Willingly.
心甘情愿地。
Willingly, knowingly, purposefully.
心甘情愿地、知情地、有目的地。
Now the argument is the managers, the people they're suing, get a bonus every year. So late 2006, early 2007, they're seeing the collapse coming. But if they put it off a while, they get a little more bonus. Maybe, just maybe, they'll get a lucky break and it won't be that bad, and nobody will ever know that they had all this junk on their books.
现在的争论是经理人，也就是他们起诉的人，每年都会拿奖金。所以2006年底、2007年初，他们看到了崩盘的到来。但如果他们推迟一点，就能多拿点奖金。也许，只是也许，他们会交好运，情况没那么糟，也没人会知道他们账上有这么多垃圾。
In fact, in a way, you could say that the lawsuit against Citigroup is, you failed to defraud enough people that you were the sucker. You should have found other suckers to sell this junk to.
事实上，在某种程度上，你可以说对花旗集团的诉讼是，你没能欺诈足够多的人，所以你自己成了傻瓜。你应该找其他傻瓜把这些垃圾卖给他们。
Wait, I feel like you just lost me. Because you're saying that there was this crappy stuff on the books and somehow the manager should have found a way to sell it to somebody else, so they wouldn't get stuck with it?
等等，我觉得我跟不上你了。因为你是说账上有这些垃圾东西，经理们应该找到某种方法把它卖给别人，这样他们就不会被卡住？
They should get it off their books. Now, they could get it off their books in a legitimate way. But obviously, they weren't able to sell this stuff. Nobody wanted it. At least anywhere near the price they were willing to sell it for. So a reasonable presumption seems to be that the shareholders would have been perfectly happy. In fact, thrilled, if Citigroup had managed to get rid of this.
他们应该把它们从账上清掉。现在，他们可以通过正当方式把它们清掉。但显然，他们没能卖掉这些东西。没人想要它们。至少在他们愿意出售的价格附近没人要。所以一个合理的推断似乎是，如果花旗集团能设法摆脱这些，股东们会非常高兴。事实上，会欣喜若狂。
Right. And then maybe those other people would be suing you, but we wouldn't be suing you. It'd be some other bank's shareholders probably, but not our problem. And what I find really interesting is, if Citigroup had managed to sell some of the stuff off of its balance sheet and sell it to other people, make other people the suckers, it might not have been as bad for the system and for the rest of us as a whole.
对。然后也许那些人会起诉你们，但我们不会。那可能是另一家银行股东的问题，但不是我们的问题。我发现非常有意思的一点是，如果花旗集团设法卖掉一些资产负债表外的东西，卖给别人，让别人成为傻瓜，这对整个系统和对我们其他人来说可能就不会那么糟。
Wow. You're saying that if Citigroup had been more of a bastard, the economy would be better?
哇。你是说如果花旗集团更坏一点，经济会更好？
I am saying that. I don't think that's even controversial, actually. So here's the way the argument goes. Citigroup was the largest bank, financial institution in the country. It is hugely important to the system as a whole. So if Citigroup goes down, it brings down the rest of the global financial system with it. I mean Lehman almost brought down the global financial system. Citigroup is far, far larger than Lehman brothers and far more systemically important. So that's A.
我是这么说的。事实上，我不认为这有什么争议。所以争论是这样的。花旗集团是全国最大的银行、金融机构。它对整个系统至关重要。所以如果花旗集团倒闭，它会带着全球金融系统的其余部分一起倒下。我的意思是，雷曼几乎拖垮了全球金融系统。花旗集团比雷曼兄弟大得多，系统重要性也高得多。所以这是A。
B, they were on the brink of bringing the entire global economy down with them. And the way they got themselves to that position was because of these CDOs that the lawsuit is talking about. So it took all these crappy mortgages, and it took all these like crappy, toxic assets, and it sort of assembled them into one place, which was the Citigroup balance sheet. Which also happened to be sort of the central node of the global financial system. Instead of spreading the risk around the globe, it concentrated it all in the place where it could do the most damage.
B，他们处于拖垮整个全球经济的边缘。而他们陷入那种境地是因为诉讼中提到的这些CDO。所以它拿了所有这些垃圾抵押贷款，拿了所有这些垃圾、有毒资产，并把它们汇集在一个地方，那就是花旗集团的资产负债表。这恰好也是全球金融系统的中心节点。它没有将风险分散到全球，而是将其全部集中在最能造成破坏的地方。
And of course, we don't know anything, right? I mean, obviously this is allegations in a lawsuit. We're just saying it's really interesting. And these lawsuits are one of the only avenues we have to try and understand what happened. Because the congressional hearings have frankly, not really yet revealed much of substance about what was going on inside the banks. The banks themselves haven't told us an awful lot.
当然，我们什么都不知道，对吧？我的意思是，这显然是诉讼中的指控。我们只是说这非常有趣。而这些诉讼是我们试图了解发生了什么的唯一途径之一。因为国会听证会老实说，还没有真正揭露关于银行内部到底发生了什么的实质性内容。银行本身并没有告诉我们太多。
Right. And one of the things that seems like out there is there's this sense that surely, something criminal must have been going on. That something this bad doesn't just happen by accident or by random sort of mistake. And so there must have been somebody at the heart of this who knew, I'm doing a bad thing. And these lawsuits are sort of like one of the things that's going to help us figure out if that was actually true.
对。有一种感觉是，肯定有什么犯罪行为在进行。这种坏事不会仅仅是意外或某种随机错误造成的。所以一定有人是核心，他知道，我正在做坏事。这些诉讼是帮助我们弄清楚这是否属实的途径之一。
Adam Davidson and Alex Blumberg. Their reporting on the economy is a co-production of our show and NPR News. They'r thrice weekly podcast, Planet Money , is at npr.org/money.
亚当·戴维森和亚历克斯·布隆伯格。他们关于经济的报道是我们节目和NPR新闻的联合制作。他们每周三次的播客《Planet Money》在npr.org/money。
"Act four, Man in the Mirror."
“第四幕，《镜中人》。”
You know how in big families there's often one kid who's the default to get blamed and take the fall when something happens? Shalom Auslander came from a small family, so in his family who would take the fall was usually up for grabs. And he very much did not want it to be him.
你知道在大家庭里，总有一个孩子是发生事情时默认的替罪羊吗？沙洛姆·奥斯兰德来自一个小家庭，所以在他家里谁背黑锅通常是随机的。而他非常不想成为那个人。
I was not a brave child. I was scared of heights. I was scared of non-Jews. I was scared of Nazis. I was scared of Arabs. I was scared of ET, the extraterrestrial. I was scared of the black people who lived in the town to the left of us, and I was scared of the Hasidic Jews who lived in the town to the right of us. I was scared of my father. I was scared of God. I was scared of the dark. I was not a brave child.
我不是个勇敢的孩子。我恐高。我害怕非犹太人。我害怕纳粹。我害怕阿拉伯人。我害怕《ET外星人》。我害怕住在我们左边镇上的黑人，我也害怕住在我们右边镇上的哈西德派犹太人。我害怕我父亲。我害怕上帝。我害怕黑暗。我不是个勇敢的孩子。
I was eight years old and had a downstairs bedroom and I was afraid to come out at night. The bathroom lay on the far side of the den. And though the agony in my loins was often unbearable, I would rather have died of a burst bladder, then fall prey to the non-Jews, Nazis, Arabs, black people, extraterrestrials, and Hasidic Jews, who were lying in wait beneath the sofa bed next door. And so I spent my nights in the fetal position, in torment, waiting for my kidneys to fail. And wondering what would happen when they did.
我八岁时住在一楼的卧室里，晚上不敢出来。浴室在休息室的另一边。虽然腹股沟的疼痛经常让人难以忍受，但我宁愿因膀胱爆裂而死，也不愿落入那些潜伏在隔壁沙发床下的非犹太人、纳粹、阿拉伯人、黑人、外星人和哈西德派犹太人的手中。于是我整夜蜷缩成胎儿姿势，备受煎熬，等待着肾脏衰竭。并想知道在那之后会发生什么。
One day I came home from school to find my mother in the den, opening the sofa bed, and putting on fresh sheets. Grandma Ida is going to be living with us for a while she said.
有一天我放学回家，发现母亲在休息室打开沙发床，换上新床单。她说，艾达奶奶（Grandma Ida）要和我们住一段时间。
Why?
为什么？
Grandma Ida had been diagnosed with Alzheimer's a few months earlier. And as the disease was progressing rapidly, she was no longer able to take care of herself. She needs our help said, my mother. Grandma Ida was my father's mother, 4 feet and 10 inches of compressed fury and discontent, wound as tightly as the silver hair bun on the top of her head.
艾达奶奶几个月前被诊断出患有阿尔茨海默病。由于病情迅速恶化，她已无法照顾自己。母亲说，她需要我们的帮助。艾达奶奶是我父亲的母亲，一个充满愤怒和不满的4英尺10英寸的小老太太，性格像头顶上的银色发髻一样紧绷。
She came to our house and scowled. She scowled at me, and she scowled at my brother. She scowled at the food my mother cooked. And she scowled at my father for scowling at the very same food she had just scowled at.
她来到我们家，总是皱着眉头。她对我皱眉，对我的兄弟皱眉。她对我母亲煮的饭皱眉。她还对我父亲皱眉，因为他对我母亲刚刚煮好的、她也皱着眉头的饭皱眉。
I had a recurring dream about her. It is Sukkot, the Jewish feast of Tabernacles. Grandma is sitting next to me. She looks at me and scowls. Why don't you finish your meat, she says.
我曾梦到过她。那是住棚节，犹太人的节日。奶奶坐在我旁边。她看着我，皱着眉头。她说，你为什么不吃完你的肉？
I'm not hungry, I reply.
我回答说，我不饿。
Your mother worked hard to make that.
你妈妈辛苦做了这些。
How come you're not eating it then, I ask. And with that, Grandma scoops me up in her arms, carries me away from the table, and throws me down the stairs.
我问，那你怎么不吃呢？说完，奶奶把我抱在怀里，带离餐桌，扔下楼梯。
You can come back up, she says, when you learn some respect.
她说，等你学会礼貌了再上来。
I had a dream about her, I said to my mother.
我对妈妈说，我梦到她了。
Oh, she said, pulling on the pillow cases.
她说，哦，一边拉扯着枕套。
She threw me down the stairs.
她说，她把我扔下楼梯。
Why?
为什么？
Because I didn't finish my dinner.
因为我没吃完晚饭。
Stop being ridiculous, said my mother. Your grandmother, she added unconvincingly, loves you.
我妈妈说，别胡思乱想了。接着她难以置信地补充道，你奶奶爱你。
Noodles looked up and growled.
面条（Noodles）抬起头，咆哮着。
That dog, my mother said, is a ticking time bomb.
我妈妈说，那只狗是个定时炸弹。
Noodles was my white, curly-haired poodle-something mix. I was the only one in the family that understood Noodles, and he was the only one who understood me. I loved Noodles not just because of who he was, but because of who he hated. Noodles hated my father. My father was a frightening man, with broad shoulders, thick fingers, and a short temper. But Noodles didn't care. Noodles growled when my father came home. He growled when my father walked across the room. He growled when my father got up to go to bed.
面条是我的白色卷毛贵宾犬混种。我是家里唯一理解面条的人，它也是唯一理解我的人。我爱面条不仅是因为它本身，还因为它讨厌的人。面条讨厌我父亲。我父亲是个可怕的男人，肩膀宽阔，手指粗壮，脾气暴躁。但面条不在乎。我父亲回家时，它会咆哮。我父亲走过房间时，它会咆哮。我父亲起身去睡觉时，它会咆哮。
Lousy mutt, said my father, closing his bedroom door behind him.
我父亲关上卧室门说，该死的杂种。
Good boy, I whispered.
我低声说，乖孩子。
That dog, said my mother, is a ticking time bomb.
我妈妈说，那只狗是个定时炸弹。
One week later, Grandma Ida moved in. My mother had explained to me that Alzheimer's is a degenerative disease, which affected parts of the brain. Grandma couldn't remember my name, or the name of my siblings, and she was wearing a diaper because she was losing control of her bowels. She looked even smaller than I remembered, and as I watched her struggle up the front steps of the house, my fear of her was replaced with sorrow and pity.
一周后，艾达奶奶搬了进来。母亲向我解释说，阿尔茨海默病是一种退行性疾病，会影响大脑的某些部位。奶奶记不住我的名字，也记不住我兄弟姐妹的名字，因为她正在失去对肠道的控制，所以穿着纸尿裤。她看起来比我记忆中更小，当我看着她挣扎着爬上前门台阶时，我对她的恐惧变成了悲伤和怜悯。
Hi, Grandma, I said, giving her a hug. Don't hi me, said Grandma. And stop pulling.
我给了一个拥抱，说，奶奶好。奶奶说，别跟我好。别拉拉扯扯。
Whatever parts of my grandmother's brain the Alzheimer's was affecting, it clearly hadn't yet spread to her scowl lobe, or her central anger cortex. She scowled when she saw her room, scowled when she learned that I would be sleeping next door.
无论阿尔茨海默病影响了奶奶大脑的哪一部分，显然还没有蔓延到她的皱眉叶或核心愤怒中枢。她看到自己的房间时皱眉，得知我将睡在隔壁时皱眉。
A strange man like that, she complained. And scowled when my mother served dinner.
她抱怨道，那种奇怪的人。然后当母亲端上晚饭时皱眉。
How are you feeling, Grandma?, I asked passing her the potatoes.
我把土豆递给她问道，奶奶，你感觉怎么样？
Laugh now, she said, you'll die soon too. Then we'll see who's laughing.
她说，趁现在笑吧，你很快也会死的。到时候看看是谁在笑。
That night I had a dream about her. It is Sukkot, the Jewish feast of Tabernacles. Grandma is sitting next to me. She looks at me and scowls. Then comes the scooping, then the carrying, then the throwing me down the stairs.
那天晚上我梦到她了。那是住棚节。奶奶坐在我旁边。她看着我，皱着眉头。接着是抱起、背负，然后把我扔下楼梯。
I woke up. It was late and my heart was racing. And as usual, my bladder was bursting. I tip-toed to my bedroom door and looked across the darkened room to the bathroom that lay beyond. I thought for a moment that I would be safe crossing the room with Grandma there. But it took her five minutes to get out of bed and the Nazis would be finished with me in just one.
我醒了。时间很晚了，我的心跳得很快。像往常一样，膀胱快要胀破了。我踮着脚走到卧室门口，看向黑暗房间另一头的浴室。有一刻我以为奶奶在那儿，穿过房间会很安全。但她起床要花五分钟，而纳粹只需一分钟就能解决我。
Perhaps it was the opening of my door, perhaps it was a breeze coming from the window, but as I was turning to go back to bed I noticed a faint pee smell. She was, I thought to myself, an old woman. Accidents, I realized, happen. A little extra pee I figured, wouldn't hurt anyone.
也许是因为我打开了门，也许是因为窗户吹进了微风，但在我转身回床时，我闻到了一股淡淡的尿骚味。我想，她毕竟是个老太太。我心想，意外总是会发生的。多出一小滩尿，我想不会伤害任何人。
And so as Grandma Ida lay sleeping just 10 feet away, I stood at the edge of my bedroom, pulled down my pajama bottoms and peed on the orange shag rug that covered the den floor. I was not a brave child.
于是，当艾达奶奶在仅仅10英尺外熟睡时，我站在卧室边缘，脱下睡裤，尿在了覆盖休息室地板的橙色长绒地毯上。我不是个勇敢的孩子。
I woke the following morning to a soft hissing sound coming from next door. Watch where you step said my mother. She was emptying a can of Glade air freshener into the air. There was a pail of water on the rug beside the spot where I had peed the night before, along with an old scrub brush and some rags.
第二天早上醒来时，听到隔壁传来轻微的嘶嘶声。母亲说，走路小心点。她正往空气中喷洒罐装空气清新剂。我昨晚撒尿的地毯上放着一桶水，旁边还有一把旧刷子和一些碎布。
What happened?, I asked.
我问，发生了什么？
Your grandmother had a little accident, she said. That's all.
她说，你奶奶发生了一点小意外。就这样。
What kind of an accident?
什么样的意外？
An accident, that's what Kind Get some breakfast, you'll be late for school.
意外，就是那种。快去吃早饭，上学要迟到了。
She took off her rubber gloves and followed me upstairs. Grandma was in the kitchen scowling at her oatmeal.
她脱下橡胶手套，跟着我上了楼。奶奶在厨房里对着燕麦粥皱眉。
Good morning, Grandma, I said.
我说，奶奶早安。
Says you, said Grandma. Noodles growled.
奶奶说，随你。面条咆哮着。
That dog, said my mother, is a ticking time bomb.
我妈妈说，那只狗是个定时炸弹。
I was deliberate. I was careful. I never peed on the same spot two nights in a row. I peed as far away from my bedroom door and as close to Grandma's bed as possible. Every so often, I simply stood at my door and swiveled my hips, sprinkler style, so that the location of the pee could never be accurately identified.
我很有分寸。我非常小心。我从不在连续两晚在同一个地方撒尿。我尽量远离我的卧室门，尽可能靠近奶奶的床。偶尔，我只是站在门口扭动臀部，像洒水器一样，这样撒尿的位置就永远无法被准确识别。
This whole house smells like a god damn toilet, said my mother.
我妈妈说，整个房子闻起来像个该死的厕所。
She's an old woman, I said.
我说，她是个老太太。
She bought some air fresheners with names like lavender meadow and orchard nectar Carpet Fresh, and spent Sunday morning cleaning, and scrubbing, and blotting, and dabbing. But the house still smelled like a toilet. It smelled like a toilet someone had stuffed with flowers.
她买了些空气清新剂，名字叫“薰衣草草甸”和“果园花蜜”，还有地毯清新剂，花了周日早上打扫、擦洗、吸干和拍打。但房子闻起来还是像个厕所。闻起来像是个塞满了鲜花的厕所。
She bought my grandmother new diapers. Now with elasticized legs, said the box. For greater comfort and security. And she covered the mattress with an absorbent deodorizing mattress pad.
她给奶奶买了新尿布。包装盒上写着，现在带有弹力腿部设计。为了更舒适和安全。她还用吸水除臭床垫垫覆盖了床垫。
I began to enjoy the peeing. It wasn't just that it was the perfect crime, it's that it was the perfect justified crime. My father was violent, my grandmother was bitter, my mother was manipulative, and I had a weak bladder. Peeing on our house felt good. It felt right. I'd wanted to pee on our house for some time, and it soon occurred to me that there was really no reason I couldn't pee in other rooms too. Grandma wasn't restricted to the den. I could pee anywhere she went. And so I did. During breakfast, during dinner, while they were downstairs watching TV. I peed in my sister's room, I peed in my parents' room, and I peed in the dining room.
我开始喜欢上撒尿了。这不仅是因为它是完美的犯罪，更是因为它是完美的“合理”犯罪。我父亲暴力，奶奶刻薄，母亲操纵，而我膀胱虚弱。在我家里撒尿感觉很好。感觉是对的。我早就想在家里撒尿了，很快我意识到没有理由不能在其他房间也撒尿。奶奶不限于休息室。她去的任何地方我都可以撒尿。所以我照做了。早餐时、晚餐时、他们下楼看电视时。我在妹妹房间撒尿，在父母房间撒尿，还在餐厅撒尿。
To avoid suspicions, I even peed in my own bedroom a couple of times. The house may have smelled like a toilet, but for the first time, in a long time, I felt happy.
为了避免怀疑，我甚至在自己的卧室里也撒了几次。房子闻起来可能像个厕所，但这是很久以来第一次，我感到快乐。
And then one day, less than a month after Grandma arrived, I came home from school to find my mother waiting for me in my bedroom.
然后有一天，在奶奶搬来不到一个月后，我放学回家发现母亲在卧室等我。
We need to talk, she said.
她说，我们需要谈谈。
About what?, I asked.
我问，关于什么？
About Noodles.
关于面条。
Noodles always met me at the door when I came home from school. And looking around, I noticed he was missing.
面条平时我放学回家时总会在门口迎接我。环顾四周，我注意到它不见了。
Where is he? I asked. Your father took him.
我问，它在哪儿？你父亲带走了它。
Took him?
带走了它？
That dog, said my mother, was a ticking time bomb.
我妈妈说，那只狗是个定时炸弹。
Took him where?
带到哪儿去了？
He's been peeing on the floor, said my mother.
我妈妈说，它一直在地板上撒尿。
He has not.
它没有。
Who was it then?
那会是谁？
It was Grandma, I said.
我说，是奶奶。
Grandma wears diapers, said my mother. It was Noodles. And he nipped your father again.
我妈妈说，奶奶穿着尿布。是面条。而且它又咬了你父亲一口。
Where did he take him? I demanded, my eyes beginning to fill with tears.
我追问，他把它带到哪儿去了？眼眶开始蓄满泪水。
He took him to the pound, she said. He'll find a new home and we'll find a new dog.
她说，他把它带到收容所去了。它会找到一个新家，我们会找到一只新狗。
I don't want a new dog, I shouted. It was Grandma. I threw myself on the bed, buried my face in the pillow, and cried. Noodles, I wailed. Noodles.
我大喊，我不要新狗。是奶奶。我扑在床上，把脸埋进枕头里哭了。我哀嚎着，面条。面条。
My grandmother stopped at my door and I looked up at her, tears running down my cheeks.
奶奶在我的门前停了下来，我抬头看她，泪水顺着脸颊滑落。
What is that racket, she said. why is this [? meshugana making such a racket?
她（指着我）说，那是些什么噪音？为什么这个疯子在制造这么大的噪音？
He misses his dogs, said my mother. Grandma waved her hand as she shuffled away. Filthy animals, she said. I watched her go and a powerful rage grew inside me.
我妈妈说，他想念他的狗了。奶奶挥挥手蹒跚走开。她说，肮脏的动物。我看着她走远，一股强大的怒火在我心中滋生。
OK, I thought. Now it's personal. It wasn't just that they had punished the wrong person, it was that they had punished the wrong, wrong person. Sure, OK, yes. I was peeing on the floor. But Grandma was peeing in her pants. The only one not peeing where he wasn't supposed to was Noodles, and now he was gone.
我想，好吧。现在这是私人恩怨了。不是因为他们惩罚了错误的人，而是他们惩罚了最不该惩罚的人。当然，好吧，是的。我是在地板上撒尿。但奶奶是在裤子里撒尿。唯一没有在不该撒尿的地方撒尿的是面条，而现在它走了。
I drank. I drank water, I drank soda, I drank lemonade, I drank tea. I peed in the den, I peed in the kitchen, I peed in the foyer, I peed on the carpeted stairs.
我喝水。我喝水、喝汽水、喝柠檬水、喝茶。我在休息室撒尿、在厨房撒尿、在门厅撒尿、在地毯楼梯上撒尿。
For the first few days my parents still blamed Noodles.
最初的几天，我父母仍然责怪面条。
That damn dog, my mother said. Scrubbing her way down the stairs. You see what he did to this house?
我妈妈一边擦着楼梯一边说，那只该死的狗。你看看它对这个家做了什么？
But when new pee spots continued to appear, it was clear to everyone that a grave miscarriage of justice had been done. The peer was still in the house.
但当新的尿点不断出现时，很明显一场严重的冤假错案发生了。撒尿的人还在屋里。
I drank and I peed, and I drank and I peed. And then, one day, I came home from school and Grandma was gone.
我喝水、我撒尿，我又喝水、又撒尿。然后，有一天，我放学回家，奶奶不见了。
We need to talk, said my mother.
我妈妈说，我们需要谈谈。
About what, I asked.
我问，关于什么？
About Grandma. My mother's sighed and explained that they found Grandma a home where she could get the care and attention she needed.
关于奶奶。母亲叹了口气，解释说他们给奶奶找了一个可以获得所需照料和关注的家。
Can we get Noodles back? I asked.
我问，我们能把面条带回来吗？
It's in Brooklyn, said my mother. Nice of you to ask.
我妈妈说，在布鲁克林。你问得真好。
Can we get Noodles back?
我们能把面条带回来吗？
It's not that simple, she said. And then she explained what happens at the pound to dogs that get returned. And to dogs that nip. And what the expression "put down" means. And I felt the strength drain out of my legs and I sank onto the couch and buried my face in my hands.
她说，没那么简单。然后她解释了收容所里被退回的狗会发生什么。以及咬人的狗会发生什么。还有“安乐死”是什么意思。我的双腿力量被抽空，瘫倒在沙发上，双手掩面。
Hey, she said rubbing my shoulder, we'll get another dog.
她拍着我的肩膀说，嘿，我们会再养一只狗的。
What had started with pee on the carpet had ended with blood on my hands. I was angry at Grandma, but I didn't want them to put her down too. I thought about being brave, about owning up to what I had done. But I wasn't brave. I knew my father would kill me, and then there'd be three dead bodies. And so I took a deep breath, told my mother I wanted to get a big dog this time. And together, we went upstairs for dinner.
从地毯上的尿迹开始，以我手上的鲜血结束。我生奶奶的气，但我不想让他们也把她“解决掉”。我想过勇敢一点，承认我所做的一切。但我不够勇敢。我知道我父亲会杀了我的，那就会有三具尸体了。于是我深吸一口气，告诉母亲我这次想养一只大狗。然后我们一起上楼吃晚饭。
Shalom Auslander is the author of several books, including most recently, Foreskin's Lament.
沙洛姆·奥斯兰德是几本书的作者，其中包括最近的《包皮的哀歌》。
Our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Sean Cole, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help of [? Andy Dixon. ?] Seth Lind is our production manager. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
今天的节目由简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）参与了制作。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。制作助理是安迪·迪克森（Andy Dixon）。赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。音乐支持来自杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who swears that he will not take the fall. It was not him who stole the plagiarism copy of Car Talk's Greatest Hits.
《This American Life》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我们节目的管理监督人是我们老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，他发誓他绝不会背黑锅。偷走《Car Talk》精选集剽窃拷贝的人不是他。
But I didn't do it. I frigging wasn't even there. The things weren't even there.
但我没干。我他妈当时根本不在场。那些东西根本就不在那儿。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories on This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多故事回到《This American Life》。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。